j'ai rappelé aux conseillers du premier
ministre que la ville de lure avait
perdu de nombreux services publics et
que la volte face du gouvernement actuel
sur le centre de détention était la
goutte d'eau qui faisait déborder le
vice des conseillers du premier ministre
ont confirmé ce que je savais à savoir
que la décision du gouvernement de ne
pas construire comprise en allure qui
était irréversible
mais on m'a invité à à bâtir un contrat
territoire spécifique qui pourrait
inclure outre des mesures qu'il avait
déjà été annoncée par nadine bourreau à
un ministre de la république
l'implantation d'un équipement public
allure dans des domaines à explorer la
justice la santé la sécurité les
finances et donc je vais travailler à
l'élaboration de ce contrat et je vais
prendre au mot bien entendu les
conseillers du premier ministre pour
implanter une nouvelle activité publique
à nouveau service public allure c'est un
deal entre guillemets qui vous convient
c'est un deal qui peut m'intéresser à
condition qu'il soit suivi d'effets chat
échaudé craignant l'eau froide
je vais pousser jusqu'au bout la logique
qui m'a été proposé et je vais prendre
au mot les conseillers du premier
ministre à travers les paroles et les
propos qu'ils ont tenus ce matin devant
moi
boucles d'aylmer refusait d'avoir une
prison
j'ai expliqué que pour moi en terme
d'aménagement du territoire
cette décision était aberrante que
l'urée étaient volontaires pour
accueillir un centre de détention que
d'autres communes orb articulant val de
marne ne l'était pas que le choix qui a
été fait me paraissait logique le
gouvernement invoque d'autres arguments
qui ne sont pas les miens mais j'ai une
proposition de substitution je vais
l'étudier
la faire prospérer et faire en sorte
qu'elles aboutissent sur tout